I do cook every single day, you know, Drew.
So I'm gonna show you how to make one
of my favorite Rossipes ever.
Rossipes!
This is split pea soup with a little twist.
Mm.
It's a Rossipe. Ta-da.
(audience applauds)
All right, so you know I cook every day,
and I like to sort of tip things on their head
and make my version of them.
This actually came out of a pandemic.
There was a day I wanted to cook something,
it was a weekend, and I had like nothing in the house.
And so I thought, what do I have?
And I actually had some split peas and some chorizo.
What? What do you do with that?
Well, I'm gonna turn this on its head.
I have some onions and carrots sweating
in a little bit of olive oil.
We're gonna do a little salt and pepper in here.
And if you're open to a little heat,
I like to do some red pepper.
And you can just, crushed red pepper, you know?
Yes, please.
Do as much as you want.
I'm old. My palate is dull.
Once those are sort of translucent,
we're gonna add two cloves of garlic.
You just wanna brown it slightly.
Mm-hmm.
And then I have about eight cups of chicken stock.
You can use veggie stock if you want to.
Now we're gonna add some herbs.
I do some dried oregano in here.
I put one bay leaf, which we're gonna get out later.
Here's some fresh thyme.
You can use dried, too, if you want.
And now is when my split pea soup goes a little crazy.
Hmm.
We're gonna put smoked paprika in there.
(dish clanging)
Right? Why?
Because I'm going to take this dried chorizo,
it's a hard chorizo sausage, right?
In here are spices like paprika, chili powder. Yummy, yummy.
And while the soup cooks and boils,
all those spices are gonna render into the broth,
seasoning our entire broth.
Then you take your split peas
and put them into this broth as well.
How long does this cook now?
Because I think some people are unintimidated
and some people are like, how long do I cook the lentils?
I would say a couple hours you're gonna want this
to cook down.
Okay.
So now is when we're gonna take our tongs
and grab this chorizo and take it out of here.
Oh, my gosh, Ross.
Can you smell it?
This looks incredible.
So set this aside.
We're actually going to let this cool, the chorizo.
And once it has cooled, we're gonna dice it.
So you'll notice right now,
our split pea is a little chunkified still,
and you can serve it like this.
But I thought it'd be fun to get this bad boy out.
You guys are ever work with an immersion blender?
(blender whirs)
Oh, yeah. Hey.
This is very dangerous
(audience laughs)
and fun, but you immerse it
into-
Oh, shoot.
Yeah, be careful.
I was gonna say the best thing to do
is to stick it in the soup,
and then turn it on.
(audience laughs)
Yes, you don't wanna turn it on
and then put it into the soup
'cause it'll all go all over the kitchen.
Yes, exactly. Ugh.
Oh, shoot, I forgot to take the bay leaf out.
Ah, man.
Uh-oh.
Well, okay. So take the bay leaf out.
That's very important.
(audience laughs)
See, what's fun about the kitchen
is that it doesn't matter if you mess up
because no one's watching unless you're on television.
So hi.
Yes, exactly.
(Drew and audience laughing)
Okay, so let's scoop up a little bowl here.
Mm-hmm.
Okay.
All right, we have our soup here.
Now remember that chorizo?
I can never forget it.
Okay, we're gonna,
(audience laughs)
we're gonna garnish our soup with it,
because just like when you cook it with the ham hock
and bits of ham come in, we wanna taste that.
And then I do just a little green onion scallion on top.
Oh, I love scallions.
Because it's gorgeous that way.
Garnish is, it's so holy.
I will say this.
Mm.
When I wanted
a little something something
in my vegetarian version of things,
I would do little croutons.
Yeah, you could do croutons
or you could toast garbanzo beans
with some chili powder on top.
It's just about texture on the top of the soup, right?
You want a little crunch.
Yeah.
So Drew, you think you know split pea soup.
Are you ready to taste mine, split pea with a pow?
That's hot.
(audience laughs)
Oh, my God. It is delicious.
What are you getting?
A nice smoke.
Mm-hmm.
A really good saltiness.
Which I have to say bland split pea is not good.
No.
This is seasoned perfectly.
Thank you.
I love the texture of the scallions and the chorizo.
It's really wonderful.
This is, I am not BS'ing you, Ross.
I'm not capable of it.
This is one of the best split peas I've ever had
in my life.
Thank you so much.
(audience applauds)
Well, and it really came out of just experimenting.
I would just encourage everybody out there.
There's classics.
We all know them. We all love them.
But see what happens when you twist them up.
And sometimes, it's just whatever's in your pantry.
(audience laughs)
I have to say,
I feel like the flavor and the salt content coming
from the sausage is very different than the ham,
and I really love it.
And there is that smoke in it.
Mm-hmm.
Like ham no more, sausage forever.
It was a whoa moment when I thought of it.
Good.
You're welcome.
(audience applauds)
(Ross giggles)
(upbeat pop music)